.
- Bonsoir, M. Roy.
a dit : "Parmi cette poussée
qu'on voit, il y a
beaucoup de jeunes."
parler des tests rapides, là,
c'est l'essentiel de mon propos,
mais la vaccination chez
et comment ça va?DANIEL PARÉ, de
de vacc. contre la COVID-19, Qc
matin, j'ai pas encore validé
les chiffres de la journée,
à 45 % de nos jeunes partout
un rendez-vous ou bien
la dose a été administrée.
On voit certaines différences
parce que les stratégies sont
différents, mais encore là,
on est très actifs ets heureux l
que les établissements de
et de services sociaux font
présentement.ce qu'il y a des rs
qui vous inquiètent? Il
des régions où vous dites :
- Bien, vu que les stratégies
é différentes, c'est drôle
à dire, mais les régions où...
vraiment on... se présentel y a
pas eu d'entente, par exemple,
au niveau des autobus, etc.,
les chiffres tardent
les chiffres seulement
lorsque les administrations
de vaccin ont été faites.ça,
heureux de comment
ça se passe présentement.
- OK. Pour éviter que des jeuneD
et qui ont la COVID retournent
dans la classe et qu'on doive
fermer éventuellement dess, etcx
tests rapides. J'ai l'impr
que ça fait un an et demi qu'on
À quel moment... et là,
vous dites aujourd'hui que
cinq tests, les parents
qui ont des écoliers,
on avait dit ça pour les CPE.
Quand les gens auront
les petites boîtes?
- Les petites boîtes,t
les petites boîtes en question.
Au niveau des services de garde,
effectivement, on l'a annoncé,
tous les tests sont distribués
dans lt les CIUSSS,
et là, les arrangements se font
entre
et les établissements de santé.
à l'heure
où je vous parle, il y a des
niveau des centres de services
res pour distribution
dans les écoles. On a choisi
Montréal, Montérégie et Laval,
qu'on voit qu'il y a plus
de cas justement positifs.
réceptions, aux livraisons dete.
Mais on est vraiment confiants
- Là, les pat où?
Pour reprendre votre expression,
- Elles arrivent du fédéral,
elles arrivent au dépôt
provincial, et on les livreme as
centres de services scolaires.
- OK, mais elles sont rendues
où? C'est ça, ma question,
- Soit dans les camions ou soit
dans les
scolaires, et la distribution
dans les écoles va débuter
jours.
- OK, Donc demain
et au cours des prochains jours,
ça part. Et l'objectif, c'est
c'est pas pour... admettons
petite à
l'école, ce n'est pas pour moi
si je vais dans des amis. C'esté
aux enfants.
- La grande stratégie, c'est
qu'on en premier, comme on a ex,
les ge pas vacci pas vacci pas .
Deuxième phase, les écoles
primai
justement, on est en voie de
les vapas reçu leur
deuxième dose. Mais je vais vour
pulationnelle...
lorsque les tests arriveront
je pourrais rendre disponibles
au niveau de la population.
C'est en cours et je devrais
certaines annonces bientôt.
- Bon. Admettons le 17 décembre,
vendredi prochain, il y a
des rassemblements dans
des restaurants ou dans des...
bon, c'est pas encore 20tttttttt
le 23 décembre. Mais en vue de
ces rassemblements d'adultes,
est-ce que ce sera arrivé d'ici?
- Il devrait y en avoir
d'arrivés au Québec selon les
avec le gouvernement fédéral
tantôt, qui me donne des
oui, on va y arriver.
Mais permettez-moi de dire que
un outil dans notre straté
de se protéger, mais quand
on fait de la fièvre, qs de COVt
pas le temps d'aller dans
un party, dans une famille.
Ça a été la m les autre les aut,
je pense que le gros bon sens
va demeurer, au niveau
des symptômes, de bien se
s, malheureusement,
ne changeront pas cet élément,
fait que c'est vraiment
important, encore là, de bien
bon sens. De cette façon-là,toë,
un beau temps des Fêtes.
- Mais si notre enfantômes,ômes,
un petit nez qui coule,
pas de fièvre et tout ça,
et on veut par acquis
avoir le coeur net, ces tests
vont nous aider si on peut
les recevoir à la maison.e dite,
lundi, et pour la population
la semaine prochaine.s ai bien ?
- Au cours de la semaine
prochaine, j'aura population en.
Ce qu'on sait au
pour nos enfants de services
de garde, pour nres, la voie es,
on est dans notre distribu
de cadeaux de tests rapides.
Et pour la population générale,
bientôt. les doubl les doubl le,
je vous laisse là-dessus,
pour les double-vaccinés,attrape
la charge virale est plus
fiables? C'est ce qu'on vousexp?
- On va vous encourager
symptomatiques, faites le testr,
les tests sont moins précis
se déplacer dans un centre dedé,
c'est un outil, utilisez votre
il faut bien protéger
votre environnem
et c'est de cette façon
qu'ensemble, on
à vivre avec le la COVID.
- C'est la nouvelle formule,
apprendre à vivre,
Comment on fait le test?
- Écoutez, je ne suis vraiment
pas la meilleure personne
- C'est un bâton? C'est quoi?
- C'est un écouvillon au niveau
du nez. Les instructions sont
est facile, et les parents
Ça prend à peu prè
15 à 20 minutes avant
- Très bien. Daniel Par
directeur de la campagne
nous avoir parlé en direct.